I have been given the task to talk about
accidental nuclear war and what you can
do about it and in particular I'll be
giving the very challenging task of
instilling some optimism into this
before lunch
hence the smiley face so first of all in
the optimistic note raise your hand if
you are at MIT for work students or
something like that okay and raise your
take them down and raise your hand if
you are student at MIT hey that gives me
a sense of optimism that even people who
are studying for finals makes your point
of coming out here okay so first of all
the prep for the optimism part let me
just very very briefly in less than
three minutes summarize all the most
depressing things and I'm going to do it
with a very short video today I've got
guests and physicist max tegmark here to
answer some questions hey max why should
I care about nuclear weapons because
we've learned that there are even more
dangerous than we first thought the
biggest threat from nukes isn't
explosions we killed millions of people
or radioactive fallout the kills even
more or even the high-altitude
electromagnetic pulse because of a.m. by
frying the electrical grid and
electronics across the continent no the
biggest threat from nuclear weapons is a
global nuclear induced winter in which
the fires and smoke from as few is the
few thousand nukes could darken the
atmosphere enough to plunge earth into a
planet-wide mini ice age with year-round
winter light conditions this could cause
a complete collapse of the global food
system and apocalyptic unrest
potentially killing most of us seven
billion people on earth but didn't we
get rid of most nuclear weapons when the
Cold War ended well yet to know when the
Cold War ended the US and Russia slashed
their nuclear arsenals but they still
have about 7,000 nukes each which could
allow either country to create a nuclear
winter all on its own even if the other
doesn't retaliate but why should I worry
about a nuclear winter when nobody in
their right mind would start a nuclear
war unfortunately an all-out nuclear
assault isn't as unlikely as you might
think
the most likely way for a nuclear war to
start isn't political it's accidental
for example the time faulty computer
chips in u.s. alarm systems erroneously
signaled incoming Soviet missiles in the
u.s. started to prepare for full-blown
retaliation for that time when Russian
satellites mistook an unusual glint of
sunlight off clouds for incoming
American missiles and an officer averted
retaliation just by ignoring the alarm
on gut instinct or the time after the
Cold War ended when Russian radar
systems caught a Norwegian scientific
rocket was an American nuclear missile
and almost launched their missiles in
retaliation though these close calls
keep happening and sooner or later our
luck is going to run out and an entire
nuclear arsenal is going to be launched
accidentally isn't getting rid of nukes
and national security threat though well
no because it's pretty clear that a
country only needs a small number of
nuclear weapons have an effective
deterrent against nuclear attacks and
any more are as much of a national
security threat to the nation that owns
them as to the rest of the planet
so given the risks of accidental nuclear
war and nuclear winter it's stupid
dangerous and irresponsible for any
country on earth to have more nuclear
weapons than it needs for deterrence if
we continue hoarding excessive nuclear
arsenals winter is coming ok I have one
more question why should I spend my time
worrying about nukes when there's
nothing I can do about them actually
there is something you can do the
nuclear arms race isn't driven entirely
by security interests money drives it
too and politicians like to act tough
and in a time when they really should be
downgrading the US and Russian
government's to both science upgrade
their Arsenal's at a huge cost and who
does that money go to well about 2% of
the sp500 companies are involved in
nuclear weapons production while you
can't start paying taxes you can help
stigmatize nuclear arms race by
divesting from companies that produce
nuclear weapons I'll give you a link so
you can put in the video description to
a site that helps you do just that all
right Thank You max and thanks to the
future of life Institute for their
support and helped producing this video
all right
so that was a quick summary of
of much of what you've already heard
about some other speaker this morning
and then some what can we do about this
on an optimistic note well let me ask
you this question I have an offer for
you I have this really cool new
investment fund okay it's it's great
invest in building more nuclear weapons
the return on it if you want to use it
for your time and is it actually about
the same as you would get from investing
randomly on Wall Street but my fund is
but we would you like to invest in mine
instead raise your hand if so so they're
not so funny part is most of you already
are investing in my phone without
knowing it but because if you have a
raise your hand if you have any kind of
investments in any kind of stocks an IRA
or anything like that yeah raise your
hand if you have explicitly checked to
see whether it's investing in nuclear
weapons or not if you haven't you
probably are will hear a lot more from
Suzy Schneider this afternoon about
exactly how you can change that and put
your money where your mouth is and
without waiting for Donald Trump or
anybody else actually shift your money
into what you believe it there's a piece
of paper being passed around where you
can add your contact info if you would
like Richard mala who has a lot of
experience in the and investing to help
you out with it can someone raise your
hand if there is a keeper of this piece
of paper right now there it is perfect
so when it comes to you if you just
write down your contact info there
Richard or baby Lukas Perry will reach
out to you and give you more information
so you can decide what you actually want
to do that's one example something you
do what is our goal all in all about all
with all this depression depressing
stuff well to me it's ultimately very
simple raise your hand if you would like
in this current situation for us to have
even more than 15,000 nuclear weapons on
the planet okay raise your hand if you
think you'll be better to have at least
to go a little to the other direction
yeah so it doesn't matter whether you
want to get rid of them all or just have
enough for deterrence you all agree want
to go to the left here
how can we accomplish that I'm going to
summarize the rest of my talk in one
word stigmatize and spend the rest of my
time unpacking what I mean by this
exactly and again I might make you a
little analogy between how we
successfully stigmatized smoking and see
what lessons we can draw from that for
stigmatizing the nuclear arms race you
have the power they add more stigma to
things that you don't like not just when
you vote but also when you share
information with other people on
Facebook or by talking to them so we
have collected a lot of resources on our
website with this this is where you can
see this thing about the money wasting
if you want to share that video I show
the people it's here they have a lot of
other things that Union of Concerned
Scientists many others have a lot of
wonderful material please share that and
you helped help stigmatize you can also
think when you invest when you shop and
this is your Schneider will talk more
about how you can you can stigmatize now
smoking
why did smoking lack stigma when my dad
was a kid why well some smoking made
people think you were cool because
that's what all the cool news anchors
were doing and the cool actors and so on
right no it wasn't addictive at least
not according to the leading newspapers
and law and legal judgment no it didn't
cause cancer and it was even viewed as a
symbol of female empowerment right how
did the stigma gradually get added to
smoking to the point that smoking has
dropped over by fact by a factor of two
in the United States and to the point
that when I see someone smoking now at
MIT I just subconsciously I feel really
guilty about this because it's biased so
I just tactically assume they're not a
student and then I work here and the
people I do know the friends I have are
actually smokers they are all trying to
quit how does it happen well gradually
these myths got demolished by a lot of
people doing also the creative things to
get the word out what can we learn from
this well
we can look at exactly the same question
why is there not much stigma about our
nuclear policy here's my little
collection of my little top 7 list and
let's spend a little bit of time -
unpacking this one at a time I know the
risk of nuclear war ended with the Cold
War we already heard enough about why
that's not the case this is the message
needs to get out more widely shrinking
our arsenal will just make us less safe
well I just refined looked at the list
of the top 1,000 cities in the u.s. so
if Russia decided it was going to cut
back from 7 thousand nuclear them step 2
only 1,000 hydrogen bombs would that
remove their deterrent power would that
make us not worried about being attacked
by the Russians oh no because it would
still let them nuke New York Los Angeles
Chicago all the way down to great
metropolis of Green Acres Florida
Meridian Mississippi
Puyol up Washington I have - assign a
little folder for you there so you can
see how big it is and even Woburn
Massachusetts my name very close - I
live with a population of 39,000 so
raise your hand if the city that you
live in has more than 39,000 people ok
you that means you will still be
deterred even if Russia gets rid of 6/7
of its hydrogen bombs right if you do
this in Russia you get down to even
smaller cities so that clearly we don't
need 7,000 for nuclear deterrence the US
military has has come out even with the
report saying 300 was early enough will
its upgrade make it safer we've heard
enough about no way wouldn't we have
nukes only for deterrence clearly no
there's some other reasons we have until
Compellent not the turns like trying to
compel people to do things by
threatening first use and so on then
there's this whole idea that the arms
race is mainly driven by national
security that's certainly one driver but
we hear a lot more from Suzy Schneider
about how money drives it also
and finally as we heard very eloquent
between this [ __ ] grin line here if it
starts it probably will not start very
very deliberately because everybody
loses from it it will probably start by
accident so if we can get this
information out there will be more
stigma now it was I promise you to
insert some optimism into this okay to
me that most exciting thing has happened
in years
in this area is something which is
happening right now and it has to do
with the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty where in 1970 right there was a
great agreement with an it with people
who didn't have nukes agreed to keep it
that way in their turn for those who did
agreeing to a treaty working hard
towards a treaty on general and complete
disarmament under strict and effective
international control however it's
become increasingly clear to those who
didn't have nukes that there was a
little secret sub-clause to this thing
they signed on which said are just
kidding it's obviously no way that the
nuclear powers are really going to do it
and this has become so manifestly
obvious now that the rest of the world
voted late last year to start
negotiating in the United Nations to
treat nuclear weapons just like bio
weapons and chemical weapons as the
metal weapons of mass destruction that
they are to ban them why to stigmatize
not because they were not even thought
that the US and Russia and every North
Korea we're going to give up their nukes
persuade but because this was going to
add stigma okay
the new york times chose not to cover
this and then there were negotiations
that actually began just last month in
the united nations was super exciting to
be there the suzy schneider and so many
others who've been driving driving this
it would probably have been no coverage
again in new york times or any US media
if donald trump hadn't helped itself by
sending out his ambassador to stand
outside while the majority of the
world's nations and people were
represented negotiating complaining it's
always a stupid those people don't
understand and because of that
journalist came and the New York Times
wrote about how Trump was against this
and they mentioned oh by the way there's
some people are for it also like these
3000 scientists who signed this and a
few other folks really exciting energy
there and here's Beatriz seen sitting in
the back who's very much driving this
effort from the civil society side here
she is with Suzy Schneider it's striking
generally how most of the pro arms race
forces are guys most of this is done by
by women could make it that what you
wish yeah so this is a super super
exciting initiative and I wanted to take
my last minute to reflect on what where
this leaves us what I think we really
should have as a goal is to get enough
stigma around the current nuclear policy
that whenever there's a conversation in
a bar or on the hill or anywhere where
someone says one of those seven things
they will follow it up by saying are
just kidding or at least someone else in
the conversation will it just the way it
would go today if I stood here and
started to lower it over you that you
know smoking doesn't really cause cancer
to them when we get to that point
there's going to be so much more stigma
against it that the nuclear arsenals
will shrink quite under their own weight
and it doesn't have to be people in this
room a push for it there's plenty of
people with a lot of power who want to
use all that money for other things
right so as soon as there is more stigma
it Strength's them since everybody else
and things start moving in the right
direction so that's my optimistic
message before lunch thank you
[Applause]
[Music]